when Captain America the Winter Soldier
opens on Friday April 4th it will be
Marvel Studios ninth movie in six years
all have done well at the box office
some phenomenally so how do they do it
here are four keys to Marvel's success
stick to the comics for years Hollywood
screenwriters tried to redo Marvel's
Ironman origin story because they
thought the one in the comic books
didn't quite work my turn
but then Marvel said no let's just do
that an Iron Man grossed 585 million
dollars in its first year the company
has tried to stay faithful to the comic
books ever since
don't cast mega stars Chris Hemsworth
was a relative unknown when he was cast
to play Thor which made 450 million
dollars when it came out in 2011 last
year a Thor sequel made 640 million
dollars Hemsworth celebrity didn't
overshadow the character and Marvel
didn't have to pay Hemsworth a ton of
money for either moving it takes a
universe years ago Marvel sold the
rights to spider-man to Sony for a
pittance which the company now knows was
a huge mistake but Marvel has a universe
of more than 5000 characters with
storylines like Iron Man's and Thor's
that can weave in and out of each other
culminating in a mega project like The
Avengers and finally never forget the
sequels world war ii movies don't sell a
lot of tickets these days so you might
think Marvel would have moved Captain
America's origin story to the present
day but the studio took the long view
the character would start in the past
then be brought into the present giving
him enough fish-out-of-water angst to
fuel a string of Secrets the first
Captain America made 370 million dollars
the sequel is on track to who's been
better
and a third installments already in the
works
you